indian starting pitcher he's coming off
a terrific start against the tigers
where he went eight innings went into
the ninth with the shutout ended up
letting two guys on base in the ninth
they took him out ended up giving
getting a run on his uh
resume but uh he got win number seven
he's been outstanding only allowed six
hits and that one run aloud he had six
strikeouts he was moving it around this
will be his first ever start against the
blue jays
co1 swung on and popped up back at first
shallow right field long run naylor
bowers they're both there and it drops
in fair
[Music]
nobody touched it and it dropped in just
inside the line and simeon has a bloop
double to get it going
right field nailer back
hey he makes the catch and hangs on it's
out number two
simeon tags and goes to third that's a
heck of a catch by naylor
we just mentioned the win is playing
lots of tricks on the outfielders
well ross stripling the 31 year older
will be today's northern ohio hyundai
starting pitcher for the jays he's
making his seventh start in the year his
fourth on the road in his last outing he
came out of the bull benefits seven
scoreless innings two hit baseball seven
strikeouts that was the longest relief
appearance in blue jays history
two down to the base is empty and the
3-2 on the way and the fastball check to
the right side of the infield simeon in
to play it on to teles ramirez is
retired cleveland goes one two three
could be by tuesday though not saying
he's ready but he'll be eligible by
tuesday
[Music]
rosario lost the battle with the sun
at the last moment he gave way
and comes up empty and that's going to
go is a blue pit for panic now simeon
hits one sharply off the body of ramirez
at third and he can't come up with it
even on the second opportunity
and simeon is going to reach on a base
hit
panic
so first and third one out as the blue
jays try to break through bo buchet one
two again grounded off the mound and a
nice play by the second baseman miller
to rosario and then back to first and
the ball is dropped over at first so
panic will come in to score as the blue
jays catch another break on what should
have been a double play and take a one
to nothing lead
so three very weak hits
tay oscar hernandez leads off the fourth
though and there is nothing weak about
this one a long home run to left his
eighth home run of the season and it is
two to nothing blue chips as rowdy
celeste
hits the ball well to right center field
and it's going to go
rowdy teles with his third home run of
the season and that'll make it three to
nothing blue jays
[Applause]
[Music]
reached out and made a nice backhanded
grab on the warning track for out number
two
this is very similar to the play that
naylor made in the first inning off the
bat guerrero
ramirez at first
two down
and the 1-0 swung on and hit to left
field
and with roon just in front of the fence
is guriel
and that'll be that for cleveland four
complete blue jays three cleveland
nothing
there's a ball clubbert high in the air
deep right center field and it is gone
to the bullpen
[Applause]
well one guy can hit a fastball
josh naylor who made his major league
debut against the blue jays his hometown
club
goes deep here his first homer at
progressive field this year
fifth on the season
and injects some life into that indians
dugout one to one the count on randall
grichik 3-1 blue jays top six and now
randall hits one hard down the left
field line and that's a fair ball off
the wall on the fly hit hard back into
the infield but the throw a little bit
off line and grichik in with a double
[Applause]
boy blue jays we talk about how well
this club has hit in may and this is
their final game in may and randall
grichik has just hit his ninth double
of may he is really swinging the bat
well to all parts of the field when you
look around to where he hits balls he's
hitting him all over the place
this is trouble oh no they should get
this
and eddie rosario comes flying in to
make the catch to retire the side he
gets all three here in the sixth 3-1
toronto here's the 2-2
and a broken bat wider into left field a
base hit for him ed rosario
[Applause]
a one out base runner for the tribe here
in the sixth
is their third hit of the game
well it's a line drive it's over the
head
uh the shed is short
there it is so there's a one out single
now that'll bring the tying run to the
plate
now the 2-1
[Applause]
it is playable in center field bridchek
is there
and rafael golise gets the job done end
of six blue jays three cleveland one
and it finds one in the center a base
hit so he is two for three today and six
for seven in the series
ball in a strike the shift on for
cleveland
and a curveball line to right field and
that's going to get down and get to the
fence
espinal is digging for third he'll be
held there it's a stand-up double for
maguire second and third nobody out
1-1
swung on and a fly ball to center field
this is deep enough to get a run home
backing up making the catch way back on
the edge of the track harold ramirez
espinal in the score maguire comes to
third
sac fly for guerrero 4-1 blue jays
a strike away
o-2 lifted in the air popped up pachette
back into shallow left
hernandez
and the ball game is over the blue jays
will win it four to one ross stripling
gets his first win in blue jay uniform a
couple of home runs hernandez and rowdy
tallest and a really nice win for the
blue jays buck as they go three games
over 500.